thanks to an interview lead writer jesse
stern recently gave to Forbes lots of
juicy new details about titanfall have
come to light I'm Lucy and welcome to
this drift compatible gamespot news
update stern reveals that unlike its
predecessor titanfall 2 will have a
single player campaign and that a TV
spin-off show is in the works at
lionsgate's best known recently for the
Hunger Games Movies the might also says
that the multiplayer in titanfall 2 will
be even better adding that he thinks the
game will see a multi-platform release
as it's been previously suggested if you
cast your mind back you'll remember that
the first game was only available on
xbox and pc stern went on to say that
because the first titanfall didn't have
a proper story mode players didn't get
all the answers that they were looking
for the story on tape vol 2 will focus
on grand colonial warfare that basically
equates to a retelling of the American
Revolution and the American Civil War
but in space we imagine the next
generation of immigrants moving out to
the new frontier of an inhabitable
planet rather than taking a traditional
sci-fi approach to that we wanted to
look at how that would happen
practically what the ships would look
like and with machines that were
designed for excavation and construction
demolition and working the land and what
happens when they are turned into
instruments of war what inspires us is
the junction of technological
advancement the inevitability of
conflict and war and what the next war
might look like in time for two there
will be a lot of scenes where science
meets magic but keeping it grounded and
dirty and human real
also in the Eastern reveals that a tight
full spin off TV shows in the works with
Lionsgate TV details are light on the
titanfall TV show and it sounds like
early days for it overall stern cautions
that such a project would be very
expensive in part because of the source
material we are trying to find a way to
tell a story in the world we want to be
in produce in the TV models so what do
you make of these titled to details let
me know in the comments box below or
come by me on Twitter or all the latest
on time for to make sure to keep it
games for
you